en un vídeo anterior ya vimos los
opuestos de los números pero de todas
formas en este vídeo los vamos a repasar
rápidamente empecemos con un número
positivo por ejemplo con el 4 aunque ahí
tenemos por aquí el 4 así es que tenemos
un número y este símbolo simplemente
significa un número y queremos saber
cuál es su opuesto o puesto entonces
vamos a hacer por aquí una tabla tenemos
por aquí al número 4 y queremos saber
cuál es su opuesto ahora para llegar al
4 a partir del 0 tenemos que movernos 1
2 3 4 lugares hacia la derecha entonces
para llegar al opuesto del 4 tenemos que
movernos 4 lugares
ahora hacia el otro lado hacia la
izquierda ok entonces tenemos que
movernos así uno dos tres cuatro así es
que el opuesto de cuatro es menos cuatro
ahora otra forma de sacar el opuesto de
cuatro es tomar el número y cambiarle el
signo ok si este es un número positivo
este tiene que ser un número negativo y
aquí está sucediendo una cosa muy
interesante porque este símbolo de menos
lo podemos pensar literalmente como que
estamos tomando el opuesto de este
número porque esto de aquí tal cual
significa que estamos tomando el número
que es opuesto a 4 aunque tenemos que
escribirlo
si tenemos por aquí menos 4 esto
literalmente significa que queremos
tomar el opuesto
puesto eso es lo que significa el
símbolo de menos queremos tomar el
opuesto de 4
4 y lo mismo pasa con cualquier otro
número ok si tenemos menos y luego
cualquier otro número y para no poner
algún otro número en específico vamos a
poner la letra a que podría hacer
cualquier otro número esto tal cual lo
que significa es que queremos el número
opuesto
aunque el opuesto
puesto
d
y si esto te está confundiendo un
poquito recuerda que a es cualquier
número de hecho vamos a poner una recta
numérica recta numérica con el 0 por
aquí y algunos de estos marcadores uno
de estos palitos que la verdad no
sabemos cuánto miden estos palitos puede
ser que estemos saltando muchos números
en cada palito pero digamos que por aquí
se encuentra 'a y entonces menos a es el
opuesto de a así es que si tenemos a
tres marcas hacia la derecha del cero
entonces menos a que es el opuesto de a
tiene que estar tres marcas hacia la
izquierda del cero así es que tiene que
estar 123 por aquí ok
este de aquí es el opuesto
puesto
o si lo queremos escribir de una forma
más concisa entonces
escribimos opuesto con la forma de un
menos menos
y bueno teniendo esto en mente pensando
en el signo menos como en el opuesto
podemos ver algunas cosas muy
interesantes por ejemplo qué pasa si
tenemos por aquí menos o sea estamos
tomando el opuesto pero de un número
negativo lo que yo sea por ejemplo si
tenemos menos -3 y bueno te recomiendo
que le pongas una pausa y lo intentes
así es que bueno como acabamos de decir
el signo menos significa que estamos
tomando lo opuesto
así es que esto de aquí significa el
opuesto o puesto de este número o sea de
menos 3 y quién es menos 3 pues menos 3
son tres lugares a la izquierda del 0
así es que este es menos tres tomamos 12
tres lugares a la izquierda del cero por
lo cual el opuesto de menos tres son
tres lugares hacia el otro lado del cero
aunque hoy tomamos 123 lugares hacia el
otro lado del cero y listo
simplemente 3 que también lo podríamos
escribir como más 3 y así tienen
símbolos opuestos pero generalmente
cuando tenemos un signo más lo dejamos
así sin signo bueno espero que se
entienda un poco mejor qué significa
todo esto de los opuestos de los números
y de cómo está completamente relacionado
con el signo menos y en realidad podemos
hacer estas cosas muchas muchas veces
más aunque voy a subir esto para tener
más espacio ok
podríamos hacer algo así como a ver
podríamos poner menos de menos de menos
ok y bueno esto de aquí estuve aquí va a
ser simplemente dos cierto porque aquí
dentro del rectángulo verde lo que
tenemos es el opuesto de lo opuesto de
dos macro y cada que sacamos un opuesto
lo que hacemos es irnos del otro lado de
la recta numérica
tenemos dos que de saltar dos lugares
hacia la derecha del cero pero tenemos
el opuesto entonces eso es más bien dos
lugares hacia la izquierda y luego
queremos sacar el opuesto de eso así es
que en realidad son dos lugares a la
derecha o sea simplemente dos aunque hay
todo esto de aquí es un dos pero nos
falta este símbolo de la izquierda así
es que tenemos que volver a saltar del
otro lado de la recta numérica y nos
queda simplemente menos 2 aunque yo sea
saltar dos lugares a la izquierda y esto
lo podemos hacer una y otra y otra vez
aunque aquí sí
otro signo menos volveríamos a saltar
del otro lado de la recta numérica y
tendríamos otra vez un 2